[Musique]
perte de présence très stupide
punitions inhabituelles mon droit au cœur donc pour
un dedans
et puis tu es né en prison je ne
sais pas quoi faire en travaillant
pour te sortir d'ici pour toi pour
résoudre une arme mortelle maintenant  ce que tu
vas faire j'essaie d'avoir raison
j'apprendrai à ces enfants à ne pas faire les
mêmes erreurs que j'ai fait
quand je
me réveille le matin je veux te voir
je veux voir ce gamin tu sais que nous
n'avons nulle part d'autre où rester
non je ne sais pas ce que tu ne vois pas et tu
sais que tu dois arrêter tu ne peux jamais te battre
Encore une fois, fais que quelqu'un te fasse retourner à
Alféa mais tu sais
[Musique]
l'autre message est ne me détruis pas
dois-je être amusant
paye avec la tête
[Musique]